vemos absolutamente a nadie unidad para
superar las crisis económica y sanitaria
que vive ecuador ese fue el llamado del
virtual presidente electo guillermo
lasso yo tengo los brazos abiertos como
lo he dicho ya nadie debe sorprenderle
que
en mi gabinete
se incluye a personas de otras tiendas
políticas inclusive aquellos que no
concordaron con nuestro proyecto
inicialmente
del ecuador pasa por un momento crucial
difícil la diversidad en el gabinete
ayudará al proceso de gobernabilidad la
virtual victoria de lazo se produce pese
a que en primera vuelta el candidato de
la izquierda y heredero de rafael correa
andrés árabes ganó por 13 puntos
porcentuales y luego de que el entonces
candidato indígena ya q pérez denunciara
un supuesto fraude sin embargo el lazo
aseguró que durante su gobierno la
justicia no se encargará de perseguir a
la oposición y se comprometió a luchar
contra la corrupción y la evasión de
impuestos asimismo dejó en manos de la
justicia los procesos contra el ex
mandatario ecuatoriano lazo defendió su
meta de vacunar a 9 millones de personas
en los primeros 100 días de su
administración y resaltó las
dificultades que el país vive a causa de
la pandemia de kobe 19 que actualmente
deja más de 17.000 fallecidos la
prioridad de hoy y no solamente en el
campo de salud sanidad social
si no en el campo económico es vacunar a
los ecuatorianos necesitamos que pierdan
el miedo que salgan a las calles con
seguridad y tranquilidad y así poder
reactivar la economía
este banquero conservador recibe el
poder cuando el 14 9% de la población
vive en la pobreza extrema y cuando el
país debe pagar 7 mil 400 millones de
dólares al fondo monetario internacional
y a otros organismos por lo que debe
encontrar la forma de reestructurar las
cuentas estatales